partisan symbols are becoming
non-partisan according to the
way that the culture is moving further
and further to the left most egregious
example of this just happened the other
day in the u.s navy
the u.s navy has released a new
mandatory training on
eradicating extremism in this training
the u.s navy claims that black lives
matter
is a non-partisan organization
the way this came out is because they
give examples of sort of questions you
might ask
about propriety in the military one
question one example question is
my boss is always talking about black
lives matter in the workspace
isn't that political stuff that they're
not supposed to be talking about at work
i'm gonna stop there for a second the
obvious answer is yes it is
it not only is it political stuff it's
subversive
explicitly marxist stuff that seeks to
undo the american
nation so yeah probably they shouldn't
be talking about that in the u.s
military here's the answer the navy
gives
advocating for or against a public
policy issue as here
is authorized as long as the behavior is
otherwise
lawful and the advocacy is not
politically partisan in nature
implication being that blm is not
politically partisan
first of all organizations that seek to
dismantle
our entire american system should not be
permitted
in the workplace should not be permitted
in the government
and certainly should not be permitted in
the u.s military
so that's a that's a problem in general
but even on this narrower point
blm is nonpartisan i guess that's the
case this is what the democrats have
done very successfully
they've taken contested controversial
political points of view and they've
mandated them i mean now if you say that
this example we always go back to
because it's the most ridiculous one if
you say that a man is not a woman
you are deemed not just not just a
common sense person which is what you
actually are
you're not even just deemed a partisan
you're deemed a hateful bigot who ought
to be ostracized from society because
that kind of bigoted language has no
place in america mister
if you think that men shouldn't be
allowed to go use the little girls room
we we got rid of near a tandem
that's that's great but the radicalism
is still here
this training in the navy goes on it
quote prohibits
any member of the naval services from
participating in any organization
advocating supremacist causes what is a
supremacist cause i don't i don't know
what
i think that the us navy is an american
supremacist organization right
it exists to kill our enemies that's it
that seems like a supremacist cause i
think you got to get a little more
specific here when you're talking about
these words uh it prohibits any member
from participating in an organization
advocating
illegal discrimination notice the
qualifier here
not any organization advocating
discrimination
illegal discrimination illegal
discrimination would be for instance if
a college or university disadvantaged
black and hispanic applicants that would
be illegal discrimination
it would be very legal discrimination if
it if that same college or university
disadvantaged white
and asian applicants because some
racial discrimination is not only
protected by law but
mandated by law so the navy says no the
legal racial
or otherwise discrimination totally fine
probably mandatory
the illegal discrimination no thanks or
advocating the use of force or violence
against the us government or state
government has to say that because that
is still the law
that's been the law for many many
decades in this country i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show to check out the full
episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you